[Music]
Okay. Hi everyone. Welcome, welcome. Um,
so welcome to our workshop AI
engineering with the Google Gemini 2.0
family. So as it is a workshop, we are
going to keep it super hands-on. So
please keep all computer open. Uh you
don't need any Google account um like
Google cloud account. You can use your
personal Gmail. It will be completely
free for you to use. So that's the
point. Um before we get started, can you
maybe help me understand how many of you
has used Google Gemini before?
Oh wow. That's that's cool. That's a lot
of hands. More than the last time I gave
a talk like this. Um so what um we're
going to do you have like three slides
so don't worry not too much. But we're
going to focus on Gemini 2.5. So there's
a Gemini 2.5 Pro model and a Gemini 2.5
flesh model. We're going to use the
flash model as it's available uh for
free tier via API access. So we are
going to do coding and both models are
multimodal by default meaning they can
understand text, images, audio, videos,
documents and can generate text. We also
have Gemini models which can generate
images which we are also going to use.
And we have now Gemini models which can
generate uh audio. So you can create
speech from from text. Um if you are
curious where you can find those nice
model cards with all of the feature the
model context the output tokens it's on
the the Gemini docs. Um as mentioned we
have two new um texttospech models since
Google IO last week not a week before.
Um those are really cool. you will try
and see them later. And now for the
important details. So I created a Slack
channel. If you are on the AI
engineering Slack channel, you should be
able to find it. Um feel free to use it
during the workshop. You can ask
questions. I try to regularly check uh
to answer them or even afterwards if you
have questions, complete the workshop at
home or next week. Uh I will take a look
and make sure that you get all of the
answers. And then uh we have one QR
code. Uh it's AI studio. You can also
just enter in your browser AI.dev or
AI.studio studio which will brings you
to AI studio and the other link is so
there's a github repository uh with the
workshop we are going to do the workshop
I can like now switch directly to it so
um
let's hope if the Wi-Fi give us some
freedom so the good part about a
workshop is that we have Google collabs
so there's not a lot of downloading uh
happening and it will all run in the
collab environment if you have a Google
account and the other thing is what we
need to do is in AI studio to generate
an AI key. So the GitHub repository is
now loaded. In the GitHub repository, we
have a notebooks.
Uh yeah, of course. Sorry. So in the
GitHub repository, we have a notebooks
uh folder which includes all of our four
workshops uh plus a zero one which is
basically some minor instructions how to
set up AI studio, how to get an API key
and how to send your first request. And
then uh we have one or the beginning
section will be all about text
generation um getting started getting
familiar a bit with the SDK. Uh the
second part will be all about
multimodality. How can Gemini understand
images, video, audios? How can we
generate images or audio? And then the
third um section will be about function
calling, structured outputs, the native
tools, how can I integrate Google search
into it? And then I guess um with all of
the hype currently going on, we we look
at how you can integrate MCP servers
together with Gemini using it as a model
to call the different tools. Um also
very nice. So there's a solutions um
folder. The solutions folder includes
the same notebooks but with the
solutions. So all of the notebooks
include to-do text and also some code
snippets um and some comments. So
there's a a mix between working code
snippets, code snippets which has some
pointers and straight up exercises with
to-dos for for you to do. Um I will work
with you through like the existing
snippets and then everyone can work on
the exercises. The idea is to that we
try to maybe use 30 minutes per
different section. If you for example
are already very familiar with how what
I can do with text generation and I
would like rather like look at the
multimodalities parts or at the function
calling parts feel free to like directly
jump into the section and in general we
want to keep it very open very dynamic
if you have questions related to the
content maybe unrelated please keep them
coming ask them in slap raise your hands
I'm not sure maybe we have some
microphones here as well so we can like
give it to you to uh make it super
interactive So I guess let's get
started. So if you go to the notebooks,
there's also a collab um button you can
click which opens the notebook directly
in Google Collab. And if you prefer like
a local Jupyter environment, you can try
to clone the repository. Not sure if it
works for Wi-Fi or not. Um I guess
Collab will be the easiest. And as
mentioned before, the only requirement
you basically have is a working Google
account. Can be your corporate one, can
be your private one, can be one you
create in the next five minutes. And the
first step is uh what we need to do is
basically go to AI studio for the ones
who of you who are not familiar with AI
studio. AI studio um is our developer
platform to quickly test the models to
experiment with the models uh and also
keep it very similar to the development
code you will be used. So if I try to
run a request like um maybe let's ask
something what's the AI
engineering summit I can on the right
side for example enable native tools
connected with Google search I have our
flash preview model I can run the
request and
we'll see how fast yeah the model is
thinking and the nice part here is uh I
can also directly get the SDK code from
our request as soon as it's ready so if
you are experimenting in AI studio and
you want to convert it into a Python
script or want to play around with it
extend it um that's all possible so the
engineering summit refers to several
events focusing on artificial
intelligence and engineering that's
great and that also matches like the one
from New York which was done at this
February school so what you need to do
to get your API key at the top right is
uh I can also make that bigger maybe
it's easier so we have a get API key at
the top um you go to it um sorry for
it's German uh for being it's German but
on the top right corner there should be
a create API key a blue button and in
there you should it should open um s uh
I can click it should open s model where
you can either select your Google cloud
project if there's none you should be
able to create one if yep
uh yep Of
course.
Um
parent.
Okay. Good idea. Okay. Uh once you
select your Google Cloud project or
create one, you should be able to create
one. And once it is created, um you
should have it available as a popup. If
not, you can scroll down a bit. There
are your API keys. Um and then the
second step would be to go into collab
and to go on the left side uh in the
navigation. So I can also let me quickly
change that to light mode as well. Um
but anyways left side there's a key
which is called secrets and then you
enter a name which is Gemini API key and
then the value of your API key. All of
what I walked through is also part of
the 00 um setup and authentication
notebook. So if it was too fast, you can
like look up there should be screenshot
of it where I clicked on where to add
it. If you are running locally um you
need to expose the um API key as
environment variable with the same name
should be also part of our um notebook.
So in the first cell so basically what
we try here is we check whether we are
in Google Collab. If we are in Collab
Yep.
Yeah, we don't worry like we go through
it one and then you have enough time to
like five to 10 minutes to set it up
yourself. Okay. Quickly that we
Yep.
Is there any poweroint?
No, no PowerPoint code only. Um, so we
we go through the API key setup in a
minute. You have plenty of time to do it
yourself. And if you have questions, I'm
very happy to come to your place and
help you get it created. just to
complete the the setup. So once you have
created your API key made it available
to collab or made it available in your
environment best is to open the first uh
notebook it has a super small code
snippet in it which uses your API key
and generates um uses Gemini 2.0 flash
to generate a first string. So our goal
next 5 to 10 minutes is trying to get
this working. Okay.
And again going back. So we have those
QQR codes. One is for AI studio. It's
the left one. The other one is for the
GitHub repository. You can also go to AI
studio uh AI.dev to enter AI studio or
go through Google search. And you can
find the GitHub repository on my GitHub
account. Um it's like
gemini.2.5.aiengineering.workshop.
And um I will in the meantime change the
appearance.
Yeah, sorry. Sorry.
Um, so there are in the GitHub
repository if you go to the notebook
section and each of the notebooks at the
top there's a button which opens collab
directly with the notebook.
Okay.
Okay. Quick check. Are we are we ready?
any notes?
Okay, cool.
So
the first section will be all about the
the default. Basically LLM started with
being text only. We generated a text. So
what would the first section basically
covers um all of how can I generate
text? How can I uh tech generate text
and have like a streaming response? How
can I count my tokens? It's like always
important, right? To understand how many
tokens did I use, how much will it cost?
And there are like a few exercises for
you to try out different models, try out
different prompts. It will also go a bit
into detail on how the SDK works in
terms of like which inputs you can
provide. So in the Google AI SDK, we
have um this concept of a client and
client has the the models abstraction.
And the model substraction has the
method uh generate content or generate
stream content and I can also make it
maybe a bit bigger and uh each of the or
it has parameter for the model and the
model ID is basically the Gemini model
we want to use which is defined at the
top. Uh so all of those cells use the
the same concept. So all of the workshop
section have the same. Um if you think
okay 2.5 flash is not the right model
for you, you can change it to a
different model ID. If you have like an
paid account and want to use the pro
version, you can also change it. Um
and um contents is basically our way to
provide uh data or conversations, chats
and messages to um Gemini. So the first
um test basically is we ask it to
generate three names for a coffee shop
that emphasizes sustainability
and we use the client models generate
content. We have our model ID, our
prompt and then we get our response from
from Gemini.
And um if you have already set up
everything, you can try prompting a few
things. Um ask it to explain some terms
or maybe like just change the model ID
and then we continue with um counting
tokens. So there are exercises in there
uh which don't have any code snippets.
The solutions part of the workshop has
the code. So if you are getting stuck or
if you want to look it up uh what I
added uh feel free to take a look there
but um definitely try it first yourself
if you want to get familiar with the SDK
there are plenty of other snippets or
exercises basically just to u make sure
that you understand the concepts and um
can practice it and there are other
cells which are partially done so for
example the one we have here which has
some code comments and also some to-do
calls here the idea is really to to
force you not to learn new APIs. So next
to the um generate content method,
there's also a count token um um API
which we can use to count our tokens. So
similar to our generate method, we
provide our model ID and then our prompt
here. And basically what the uh API does
is now it counts only the tokens for our
prompt since we we haven't generated
something. So we can run it um and we
get an input tokens of 11. So the Gemini
tokenizer basically converted those two
four six 89
words plus a full stop to 11 tokens. Uh
which is then um an estimate of roughly
0.00002.
[Music]
Um the count tokens API doesn't expose
the pricing. So basically what I did
here is like looked up the 2.5 flash
pricing and calculated it. Um similar to
only counting the input tokens, we often
times also want to count the output
tokens to understand okay
um how much does it cost. So in the next
uh example we basically generate content
and each response has a very nice method
which is called like an abstraction
which is called a text which allows us
to actually uh easily access the
generation but also has a usage meta
data object and a usage meta data object
includes all of our consumed tokens and
generated tokens. So we have input
tokens uh we have thought tokens. So
Gemini uh 2.5 is a thinking model. So
before generating your response, it
first generates thinking tokens
basically an abstraction where it uses
more compute to have like more room to
generate a good answer for you and then
also the candidate tokens uh which are
the response tokens at the end and
that's how we can calculate the total
cost of a request where we use the input
uh token price and then our candidates
tokens and of our tokens and um for this
case it would be um less than like zero
2 cents. Yep.
Yep.
Yeah. Is there a different price forken?
No. So, um input and output tokens are
calculated different um as
yes. So we have prompt tokens is
basically the input tokens of your
prompt and then we have the candidate
tokens which is the your response and
the thought tokens and those basically
have the same pricing and the output
tokens are much more expensive than the
input tokens because that's where the
computation mostly happens and the input
is just one encoding. So that's why you
always see like the big difference in
output input pricing versus output
pricing
more.
Yeah. So for Gemini 2.0 flesh which is
our most cost effective and cheapest
model the input price for 1 million is
10 cents and the output price is 40
cents.
So you mean like why we got 639 for
total? So that's sadly not like directly
visible to us. So we can like look up
thought summaries but basically the
model generates first of all like a lot
of like reasoning. Of course, in our
case, like we we ask it to generate a
haiku might be not like the most sorry
most difficult um prompt. Um you can
control the thought tokens with
something called thinking budget where
you can limit how many tokens the model
has to think or to reason. So you have a
some sort of a cost control, but it's
basically done dynamically based on your
prompt.
Okay. Yeah, there's also a question.
Yeah, I was just
looking
Y
yes. So um I can let me open the docs
and make make it easier. Um so um Gemini
2.5 flash is a hybrid model. So you can
use it with thinking and without
thinking and without thinking basically
the computation is much more cost
effective as um you might know like the
transformers is all based on intention
which isn't like
and bionics like kind of calculation. So
it gets bigger and bigger which means it
gets more and more computens and um
without thinking it's for us much easier
or inefficient to run. So if you set um
thinking to
uh zero or like thinking budget to zero
uh you all you will have zero thought
tokens but you have like your candidate
tokens and those candidate tokens will
then be charged with 0.60 60 cents. But
once you once you use thinking meaning a
thinking budget greater zero, you will
um pay the price for the thinking tokens
and for the output tokens. And that's
where's the the $3.5.
Yes, I will open the documentation. So
we'll see it in one second.
flag.
Yeah. So, um in any case, if you have
like any questions, the Gemini docs are
a great way to like find the answers or
like just ask Google or Gemini directly
and on the model capabilities we have
the thinking section and they are like
the thinking budgets and if you want to
disable thinking you basically set the
think it budget to zero. Uh you can
control it. It could be a integer
between like 0 and 24,000 and then
setting think budget to zero disables
thinking. So that's your way to disable
thinking.
Is the budget like a number of reasoning
to do?
No, it's tokens. So
yeah, so we we have
yeah so we have seen in our example here
we had 600 a bit more than 64 tokens. So
if we would set our thinking budget to
512, it would be a maximum of 512
thinking token.
How does it know?
No.
Okay.
I guess.
Okay. continuing uh with our um
notebook. So, and please continue
yourself like I'm like you can do it
with your own tempo even like do it
faster or slower just to make sure that
we are on like the same page. And I
guess like the most interesting part
about like streaming and like LM in
generals we all have seen it with chat
GPT is that waiting for the whole
response is a very bad user experience
right like who wants to wait like 60
seconds two minutes for a response. So
that's why um everyone now kind of uses
streaming and with the Gemini and the
Gemini SDK, it's like super easy. So
instead of having just generate content,
we have generate content stream. Same
input parameters except that we now get
um an iterator back from our um call
which we can loop over and we can like
print our uh junk or like stream it back
to our user using uh the HTTP service.
Okay,
cool.
And then similar to other models, Gemini
is a chat model, right? And um maybe you
are familiar with the OpenAI SDK where
you have the concept of messages where
you have like a different like inputs
per user turn, assistant turn, user turn
and it makes it very I would say is
still complex to manage yourself because
you need to keep track of it. To make it
easier, we um added something which is
called a chats API um which basically
does all of the state management uh on
the client but as part of the SDK. So
you can create a chat uh with your uh
model and then you can basically send
messages into the chat session and the
user um like in this case it's like we
are planning for a trip. Um we send the
message we get back the response but
also our chat session includes the user
prompt and the assistant message. So
instead of needing to create this object
of user terms and model turns, we can
directly uh continue with like sending
our next message um asking
um for some
um good food uh recommendations. And
since we are in like a conversational
setting, the model knows that we are um
or like it mentioned for us to go to
different European cities and based on
like the next request, it uses like the
whole like conversation as history um to
get our response. Uh can like also
quickly
print the response here
and
get some different examples. And then if
of course if you need to store it to a
database on general um you we have a
nice get um history method available
which allows you to basically retrieve
the complete current state and you can
like store it or update it or whatever
you want to do. Yeah,
that's only a client abstraction. So the
back end receives the same request if
you would send it like as a single
request uh with an array. It's only a
client abstraction to make it easier for
developers people to quickly build.
Yep.
And then um similar to OpenI or to other
models, you can like give the model some
kind of system instruction to have it
behave differently, responded in a
different language, make sure it
respects like policies or guideline you
provide. Um this can be done through a
generations uh config. So we have
another argument now in our model call
um next to the model ID and the content
we have a config that we can provide our
systems instructions and similar to the
systems instruction we can provide um
other um generation configurations. So
temperatures can be used to make the
generation more creative or more
deterministic. So if you for example
build a retrieve lock manage generation
where you want the model really mostly
trying to use what you provide as a
context there you would normally set the
temperature to a very low um value. If
you work on some content writing
marketing you would set the temperature
to a very high value. We can control the
max output tokens to make sure that we
are not exceeding some budget some
length and top P and top K are also ways
to make our generation more diverse.
Yeah.
Um, so let me open. So here we have the
similar in the config we have the
thinking config and in the thinking cons
you can basically set the thinking
budget or also include the thoughts uh
in your request.
Okay.
And then um I think what's very more
unique about uh what we can do with
Gemini is that we have direct direct
support for files. So in this case I
download the adventures of Tom Sawyer a
book completely store it in a file and I
use the files uh API to upload the file
to a Google cloud uh storage bucket um
there um free for you so like if you uh
don't want to use your own corporate
bucket or whatever bucket with each AI
studio account basically there's your
personal u bucket which stores the file
for I think one day But you can control
the the time to live and um instead of
um needing to provide the whole file
with your request which can be very um
intensive, you can upload it and then
instead just provide the reference to
the file and what um the Gemini API does
behind the scenes. Basically it
downloads the file on the back end and
makes it available inside your prompt.
And similar here we can um we uploaded
our book we passed it into our contents
uh list here. So we don't no longer have
like a single prompt. We have now an
array with our file and we ask it to
summarize the book and was also done
while I'm talking. And then we can also
see okay the token usage now we had for
was 100,000 tokens. So much bigger than
what we tested before. And using the
file API makes it very easy uh also to
work with with PDFs which we'll um see
in like the next chapter. And then um as
an exercise for you is um to combine a
bit all of those things. So how can I
use a book to use the chat session to
chat with our model to help me better
understand it? Yep.
It's not system.
Yep. So what you do is basically you
upload the file from your client to the
cloud into a bucket and when you send
the request part of your I mean I can
like show it. Um part of your request uh
would be only the reference to where the
file is stored and what the Gemini API
does behind the scenes is it loads the
file into where the request runs and
then puts it into the context. So you
can use now this file pointer for all
requests and you don't need to send it
every time.
And here we also have like the URI. So
that's basically where
um our file um is stored or can be
accessed as well. Yeah.
So is it only available to the chat?
to itself.
It's only available to your user. So
when you send a request, you send an API
key and this API key is basically used
to get the file. So nobody else can
access the file.
Yeah.
Okay. Cool.
So if you would use a PDF which has like
more than a million tokens basically
what would happen? You would receive an
error most likely uh with like saying
that uh the file is like too big in
terms of like a context. What you can do
is basically you can use the the file uh
the file to count the token. So we have
the file now here and we can client uh
models
count tokens
you would need to chunk it then so if it
the file doesn't fit it doesn't fit and
you would need to like think about okay
can I chunk it can I summarize it can I
maybe do use other techniques to first
extract the important information and
once I have context which is um smaller
than the maximum context of my model,
you can provide it again.
Yeah.
No,
files upload.
No, no. So, it's like but it will be
deleted. So, don't expect the file you
upload now to be there an hour or a day.
Um but you can like use the same concept
with uh vertex in your own bucket where
you have like more control over it where
you can say okay maybe I want to upload
it using a different API call or already
have it available that also works.
So there's an entry point saying use
this storage bucket
with Vertex AI. Yes.
Yes. It's roughly the same but you need
to set up the client differently.
Y
Yeah.
Yeah. Good question. So I mean we can
maybe directly jump into like the the
the this the PDF section. So um continue
with section one or jump to section two
or three directly what I will do is like
in the section two which is all about
multimodality meaning we will cover uh
visual understanding audio understanding
videos and document processing and
that's where I will like jump to. Um and
part of the
um
okay being connected
part of the uh working with PDFs
basically is so similar to what we have
seen a minute ago we have a PDF in this
case it's basically an invoice from a
supermarket um I upload it and I ask the
model like what's the the total amount
uh we can run it and what happens behind
the scenes I can show oh
it's not here. Wait one second.
Okay, we don't have the file here. I'll
upload it quickly. But what happens um
behind the scenes is we run OCR on your
on your PDF and provide the PDF as
image. Um so you don't need to do it
manually. So there's no like hey it's a
PDF let's convert it to an image and
then run OCR and then I provide the
image and the OCR that's not needed. Um
we are doing it for you.
Okay.
Yep.
Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yeah. So
OR like the image understanding is not
perfect yet, right? If we reach a point
where the model understands it like in
the same way as without the text, then I
guess there's no point. But like based
on like what we have seen and also what
the industry does is you receive better
results when you provide the OCR plus
the image. Um yeah, that's that's
basically it.
Y
the PDF itself,
do you actually look at it as an image?
Yeah.
No, I I think I I mean I don't know
exactly but I think it's just basic OCR,
nothing special, no magic and then a
screenshot of the PDF.
Yeah. So it's both. Okay. Can try again.
And we have now the PDF available in
case um the workshop has multiple
sections with files which are being part
of the repository. So if you run into
like a similar issue especially for the
image understanding part or the audio
understanding part uh and you use collab
you might need to download the files
manually and then upload it. But in our
case so we have now our invoice. I think
we can like
quickly
show it.
So I was shopping in Germany. We have a
co supermarket called Rebe and I
basically bought some butter um some
bread like some sweet potatoes and uh we
prompted it and asked okay what's the
total amount? We can see here the total
amount is like 2020. Now let's see if we
got it correctly. And we got it
correctly. And it also correctly
extracted it in German even if I
prompted it in English which I think is
like pretty cool. Okay,
let's start with the image understanding
part.
Yeah, please.
Yeah.
I'm not exactly sure what happens. I
only know that by defining the thinking
budget, you can limit how many how many
tokens will be used or generated as a
maximum and very similar to what OpenAI
has with like low medium high effort. We
have a bit more granular control. So we
could technically do the same say like
low would be like a thousand token
thinking, medium would be maybe like
12,000 token thinking and high would be
24,000 token thinking. uh and it would
then use like at a maximum those tokens
to before generating your response. But
what exactly happens I can tell you.
Yeah. So without thinking what we have
seen especially on more like math type
of question where the model benefits
from like the reasoning uh the
performance is a bit worse but for like
general everyday use especially image
understanding or like OCR you can like
easily run it without it. The truth of
it would be you need to try and I think
the the real benefit here is that you
have those granular control. So you can
run evaluation of thinking budget zero,
1,000, 2,000, 4,000 and see how it
impacts your evaluation and then you can
like calculate for yourself. Okay, how
much am I able or like what's my my
maximum cost of it and like what's the
the accuracy I need to reach.
Okay,
more questions or should we continue?
There's a question. Yeah.
No, it's like uh
there's a documentation for it, but it's
like uh JSON PDFs, all different image
types, all different video types, all
different audio types. So, all of the
multimodal um features we support. Um if
it gets a bit more specific with like
JSX file and view files for like web
development, we are working on it. But
it might I mean you will see an arrow
and the easiest way is to just replace
it with a doc txt.
No, I would say like those are like you
would need to like use like mark it down
or like another library to convert it
and then or like copy paste the input
and
Yep.
So I'm not exactly sure what the
researchers did. The only thing I know
is that we get better performance when
you provide the image plus the OCR.
So I guess there's a benefit of having
both.
saw.
Yes, kind of. So, the UI or the AI
studio of course doesn't use Python. Um,
but it calls the same APIs behind the
scenes. So, the API behind the file
upload one is the same API we call from
AI studio. We call the same exact model.
Both have the same uh exact parameters.
So you should be easily what you test
and experiment in AI studio. Can you
convert into code and run it locally?
There's also this um get code um button.
So if you are AI studio and I mean we
can quickly try uploading our invoice
again
and
acknowledge ship
and use our prompt.
So
here
and now we run basically the same
request and we can now we also have this
um it's a bit hidden. It's like this
code um button at the top which where
you can get the exact same code
basically takes a few seconds as the
Wi-Fi is super bad but here you get like
the exact same Python code where you
create your client we have our model in
this case as we uploaded it manually we
provide the document not as a file URI
we provide it directly as B 64 we have
our prompt uh we have the model request
already since we generated it and then
you can continue.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, I mean we can quickly so try
it. So, we are here. We have our PDF. I
think I guess it's very interesting to
know like how many um tokens will we
use. So, um let's quickly
count tokens. So,
If we go here,
we have our count tokens and now we use
the same contents. We have the same
model ID, we have our prompt, then we
have our PDF
and let's print our token count. And
alternatively what we also have done so
if you use the
uh response so you run a request already
you should have access to the respage
metadata. Yes. And so we have our
account token. So our PDF here is
converted into like um roughly 500 uh
tokens. Um and the the prompt we have is
like around 20. And if we compare it to
like the request we run, we see okay, we
have the same exact amount of prompt
tokens and we have prompt details. We
have our output tokens
for tokens of 42 and candidate tokens of
78.
Okay,
more questions or Yeah. Okay.
560.
I think we don't charge for the OCR. I
think one image is roughly 500 images.
Uh like 500 tokens.
Um
not for you. No.
Okay. Yeah.
So
the PDF is converted into an image and
we provide the image and if the image or
like the PDF has tables, visuals, mind
maps, uh the model is trained on similar
data. So it will definitely understand
parts of it. I mean we can we can try
it. I mean, maybe we can like search for
some mind map and ask it something.
Um, you maybe you can start thinking
about a prompt
while I'm searching for a mind map
if Wi-Fi allows us.
Okay.
Okay. We have our mind map. I guess it's
just a mind map on how to do mind maps.
Um, any any idea what you would like to
know?
Sorry.
Like this.
Okay.
I mean I'm opening it but I think on the
small scale it looks correct with how to
mind map
answers
perfect.
of the table.
Yeah. So where we have seen the most
success is that when you like separate a
bit. So there are already like very good
existing methods which allow you to
extract tables or other visuals from
documents and when you then like work
with those images and tables directly
and not like you the way how we work
changes from like previously we provided
a table run OCR then ask our question
now we directly ask the question based
on the table as the models get so good
in like the multimodal understanding
that it can combine like the different
aspects I mean we can try it maybe as a
good example as well. Um maybe we find
some nice I don't know
invoice image or something and then we
can like ask it maybe to add something
or to combine it which would be very
hard I guess for a normal model but in
general like especially Gemini is so
good with like the multimodal
understanding it also videos is like
that's like my most new favorite thing
is like take a YouTube video which is um
below one hour put put it into AI studio
and like have it summarize it or if you
have like any specific question like it
it's so much faster than like sitting
there even like watching it in like two
speeds. You get your response in like 80
seconds or something and you can like
even like ask it to extract specific
timestamps on when somebody something
was set or to help you like section it
very easily.
Sorry, can you speak a little bit
louder?
I don't think so. So, AI studio is like
very developer centric and we don't want
to do too much black magic. There are
safety filters and control which you can
configure in the SDK or in AI studio and
in studio is under advanced settings. I
have safety settings. I have all of them
off. But if you like want to filter on
very explicit content or hateful
content, we run some classifications
basically before and after to make sure
that you are not creating uh for your
users harmful content.
Okay, I have our invoice image.
Okay.
Okay. What should we ask?
How much it would cost if we subtract
the pedal? Maybe.
Yeah.
the performance.
So I sadly don't have an answer for
this. I think you can always think a bit
about like would we as a humans have
struggled to understand those PDFs if
they are like switch switched up. If yes
then most likely the model will do as
well. I think one very nice part about
Gemini AI studio and the Gemini API is
you can get started very quickly like
all of us kind of set up within like 20
to 30 minutes a free account uh with
access to Gemini 2.5 flash via API 2.5
Pro in the UI. So the best thing always
is like to test and to explore and
evaluate and even if you need to run
like a thousand PDFs it's not very cost
or like expensive anymore. So really
best thing is to run your own evals to
get some more than like I try five PDFs
in the UI really look into it and if you
have like any questions or problems like
best way is to reach out to us. We have
teams helping and building with
customers and then we can like iterate
on it together. Going back to your PDF
any question any prompt idea?
Yeah,
I know you explained about security but
there are mandated
security by law which are fire
or benchmarking automations or
guardrails
posture management
mandated by CISA.
So when I implement those rules
for uh either defense or financial
applications,
how do you just set I know that Google
is pretty strong in setting up those
security measures
from a different perspective too. How do
you integrate this app and the other
security measures.
So I guess for those type of
environments uh where you have a lot of
like compliance regulations best is to
work with Google cloud. So everything we
do in AI studio is also somewhat similar
available in Google cloud in Vertex AI
and Vert.ex AI provides more features
for those kind of use cases. they I'm
not exactly sure but um they definitely
have more like information they can
provide on how to handle all of those
things and those guardrails with Gemini
so that
you're suggesting to
go
global
Google GCP environment when I go global
on GCP environment
then there are c
performance
and uh cost being here such as
so there's a guard for bas and there's a
guard for organization based and there's
a based on the industry industry based
so
we have to split those platforms into
from most grand level.
So that's
when I do it globally at GCP levels
more expensive and as well as can be a
performance issue.
Yeah. So I know that there are regional
endpoints for Gemini and Vort.ex AI as
well. And also at Cloud Next, um they
announced a new Gemini
on device kind of thing where big
companies can buy basically a huge box
where Gemini is pre-installed and it
gets delivered to your environment. I'm
not exactly sure about the details.
Easiest is like to to do a quick Google
search and and look for it. But those is
exactly where where Vortex provides you
more features and support than AI
studio.
Yeah, thanks. One of those last uh 2025
conference uh someone from Google
also represented and that's a good
platform but I didn't know how
to
this is granular level.
Yeah.
How do you most granular level to the
global level?
Okay, maybe back to your PDF question uh
regarding uh what to ask. So instead of
like asking what the the total sum was,
I asked it to to sum up the unit prices
which worked very nicely. Of course,
it's a a very well formatted PDF in this
case, but the the image understanding is
like very good. And the new way of how
we should think about it is like I
should ask the question directly based
on the image before doing too much of
processing we we have been doing in the
past. Cool. Okay. We are now at like
half time almost. I guess it's time we
move maybe a bit away from all of the
multimodality part into more about the I
guess agendic um parts which are I would
say definitely more interesting at least
to me um especially if you combine in
with like the multimodality parts. So
um
okay um so part three is um all about
structured output and function calling.
Do you know what structured outputs and
function calling is and like how it
roughly works? Any hand signals? Yes or
everyone?
Okay, not bad.
Um
okay so
the part three um goes continues with
PDFs um as they are kind of very
interesting and also um we want to do
structured outputs. So structured
outputs is for us a way to create more
structured data structures from text. So
which we can use to work way more easily
afterwards, right? And at the end we
prefer structured output much better or
much more because we can integrate it
into other APIs. We can connect APIs and
Gemini supports or the SDK supports
pyantic. So pyantic is a very nice
Python library which lets you create
those data structures and also we can
create n nested data structures. So here
we have a recipe with a name ingredients
which is a list of strings and then we
have a recipe list which is basically a
list of our recipes and we can provide
it in our configuration. So similar to
the generation arguments or our thinking
budget, we have um a response type and a
response schema we can provide. Here we
ask it, okay, can it generate two
popular cookie recipes for us? And we
basically force it to use our um
structure and I already like nicely um
printed it here. If we look at the the
raw response um of our model, we get
back a a JSON uh with um all of the
different input fields. And there's also
a nice pass method um which allows us to
convert it back into our benic uh
schema. And then we can access all of
the
the data points. And as we had our
invoice uh we can now maybe like like I
complete the exercise with you. Um what
if we like so we ask about the total
amount right but when working with PDFs
normally we want to have structured data
as a result right text is not very
helpful for us when we want to put it
into a database or want to work with it.
We really need those data schemas and
what is very nice about Gemini is that
we can basically combine both of it. So
we use our um structured output method
with our multimodal capabilities for
files and we can
provide our um
file.
Oops.
Okay.
Oh,
we need our invoice. So maybe it's a
good example. So I didn't change the
recipe uh from our like data structure
what which we want to create and we ask
it to extract the information from our
PDF. Our PDF is an invoice from a
supermarket. So it doesn't have a recipe
name ingredients. So Gemini did not
generate or hallucinated something. So
we get back a empty recipe list. So if
we now change it to our invoice data um
we should hopefully
then see the correct extracted
information.
Yes.
So, we extracted the date, all of the
items we bought, and all of the
different prices. And with that data,
now it makes it much more easier for us
to work with. Right? If I have some kind
of automated system where I need to like
take in invoices, any kind of like PDF
document, I can now provide uh a
structured
to what information I want to extract.
And Gemini does basically all of the
matching for us, which is like super
nice. And function calling basically is
the same idea, but instead of um having
like a data structure, our output is a
name and the argument. So similar to
what we have um uh we we create this
case it's like a function declaration.
It's a structure of like how a function
signature is done. So we have a weather
function which has a name, a description
and like the properties uh which we need
to provide. Um there's the same function
but just as Python code and with
function calling we provide the function
declaration and our prompt and then the
model generates aruct a structured
output which has the function name it
wants to call and the um input and
environment or the input arguments for
how to call it. So in our case, we have
a weather function. We only have one
location. Um we provide it uh similar to
all of the other configurations in our
configuration uh argument. This time we
have tools and we want to know what the
weather is in Tokyo. And obviously
what's the weather fits into the
description of our function as it helps
us retrieve the current weather. So if
we run it, the model uh instead of
generating a nice response wants to call
the get weather method and with the
location Tokyo. If I change the prompt
to hello.
Oh,
makes sense. Uh one second.
So if I change to hello we don't have a
function call right like the model
correctly understands hey that's just a
greeting let's response and like how can
I help you so but we want to call a
function so
we have what's the weather is in Tokyo
and then the next step is for you as a
developer uh to call the function right
the models cannot call or invoke
directly the function what you would
normally then have in your um code or in
your applications a way to identify okay
which function is false could be a
simple switch statement um to check okay
what's the name and if you get a name
call the method with the provided
argument and then what you do is the
output of your function is the next user
input uh so the model generates this
name and arguments object and we provide
it as a user the output and in our case
it's the result and if we look at the
weather method we have it's basically
some dummy data about the temperature,
the condition and where it is and then
the the model generates a very nice
response. So we have user input, model
has a structured output, user provides
the a structured response and then the
model generates a very nice
user-friendly response. So we call our
function, the function returns the
weather and then the model generates a
very nice response which is the weather
in Tokyo is sunny with a temperature of
22 degrees CC and it feels like 24
degrees CC. So you can think about it.
Okay, that's how I can integrate tools
or make it or convert my LLM into an
agent more or less or a way to call
something. Um, the get a weather method
can be anything. It can be a database
call. It can be a real API call. It can
be, I don't know, reading emails,
sending emails, all of the things we
currently see with all of the MCP hype
basically going on. And MCP servers have
tools as well. And those tools of MCP
servers basically expose the same um
declarations. So an MCP servers has the
tools def defined get weather for
example if it is in weather MCP server
and it has an endpoint or a method which
you can call which is list tools and
this list tools method would then return
the schemas of our functions which look
very similar to what we have created
here. And then what you do on your LLM
side or client side is you take those
schemas from the MCP server provide it
into your LLM call and then the LLM
generates depending on the context uh
the output as well which is structured
and then instead of calling the method
on the client as we did with our get
weather you would use the MCP client
again and then call the remote tool. So
very similar to what we have done here
on the client side manually but more
abstracted away and more managed. And of
course the benefit here is that not
every one of us needs to implement the
get weather method. It's way easier to
use like the weather MCP service from I
don't know some weather provider.
Similar um you don't want to use maybe
your own personal Google Drive MCP
server. This would be if Google creates
those. So that's the whole idea why MCP
servers is kind of so cool. So and um
yeah yeah yeah
so currently we are working on improving
and extending um but currently the
suggestion is probably between five to
10 and um if you have more tools you can
use embedding models to basically filter
you have the user and what you would do
is basically run some similarity
matching between the descriptions and
like what makes sense what doesn't make
sense and then you only um put the top
tool so to speak.
I'm not sure about the claim from
Andropic and like how you do it. The
only thing I can share is that Gemini
2.5 Pro was the first model to complete
Pokemon Blue uh which ran I think for
like 200 hours straight. Um the only
like the big challenge here is like so
we have like a limited context right
which is for Gemini 1 million. So if you
would continue for two hours you would
definitely run out of like those two
like 1 million tokens and entropic. I'm
not sure what that context currently is
but I'm pretty sure two hours is not
enough to run out. So what you most
likely do is you summarize you compress
the context and the conversation and
what you provide to your model. So yes,
I'm pretty sure Gemini can run for more
than two hours, but it depends on like
what you want to solve and how you are
going to solve it.
Yep.
Is that correct?
Yeah, that's correct. So native tools
are the next section. We can go into it
um in one second. And yes the currently
the native tools are not like being
returned in a way we had with like user
assistant that's basically happening
behind the scenes and what the user gets
is the final uh good assistant response
um that's great feedback um regarding
like can we have them or not like very
happy to take it to the team I can
definitely see why it would be helpful
for you for like people to directly
build with it um but for now it's not
the case and speaking of native tools So
um Gemini can is basically trained to do
native things. So function calling is
very generic. We generate the
declaration and can try to do
everything. Uh but native tools are much
easier to use as you don't need to
define or create a declaration and they
work basically on the backend side. So
you don't need to execute anything. And
as native tools we currently have Google
search available. Um basically all of
the native tools are in AI studio here.
So we have structured output which is
not a native tool which we used to get
back the structures. Code execution is a
native tools and basically means that we
or Gemini runs code for us. So
uh function to sort the top five
cities
based on
population.
So what it can do is like run Python
code for us. So if you prompt it to
solve a task using Python,
um it should run for us the Python code.
So it generates the Python code and it
did not run it. That's a bad example.
Sorry.
Oh, did I? Ah, so my bad, not Gemini's
bad.
Use Python.
Let's see what it does. Um,
okay. Yeah, now it gets Thanks. Perfect.
So, we have some reasoning and then it
generates executable code. Executable
code is also provided via the API um
which runs for us Python. So, it writes
the Python script. It executes the code
um and it generates the mudplot lip
chart. And normally we okay in the
notebook we I have an example available
on how you get the chart. If we look
into the code execution tool. So similar
story here we run it and it returns the
markdown and you can also like it can
regenerate and return um images. So next
to code execution tool there is the URL
context tool which basically allows you
to provide a URL as part of your prompt
and we extract the information from the
website behind the scenes and make it
available into your uh context. So
instead of going to a website command A
command C command f uh we do it for you.
So in this case I asked it okay like
what is the other benefits of Python um
from like the URL you can provide up to
20 URLs in one request behind the scenes
it goes to the URL extracts the
information provides it as part of your
prompt and if we look into our prompt
yeah here uh it returned our nice smart
plot plot um chart uh which is very cool
and then a final
tool is of course Google and Google
search kind of makes sense. Um, so let
me find it. Yeah, you can allow or
enable Google search which then um
allows Gemini to use or do a Google
search behind the scenes. And what
happens here is that it takes our prompt
um in this case what are the latest
developments in renewable energies and
first it converts it into one or
multiple Google search queries. Then it
executes those those Google search
queries, provides it back to the model
and then the model generates your final
response from your user input and from
all of the search results. Currently we
don't as mentioned don't export or
expose those tool calls but um I guess
especially helpful or interesting for
um Google search is that we have uh
a crowning metadata
object.
Yes.
So we have crowning support uh which
basically allows or points exactly to
where it got or like which information
refers to which um source and also
grounding meta information which
websites there is um which websites were
crawled and in our case so we have the
yes there
so um for both code execution and
crowning and URL context we increase the
context size right those contexts will
be built uh tokens will be built uh for
Google search um there's a free tier
from I think 1500 Google searches which
are free and then afterwards I think
there are $35 per 1,000 searches uh code
execution the Python running is free um
well context text is currently in
preview. So I'm not sure what the if and
what the pricing will be. Um yeah, and I
think like what's what's very cool and
um is part of the exercise if you
already have done it or going to do it
later is you can combine those. So you
can use the Google search tool with the
URL context tool or the code exe
execution tool with the Google search
tool to
basically have it done more agentically
like first search for like what's the
latest react or Python version then
write a Python script and run it and
return it. Um which makes it very nice
to use.
Sorry.
Yeah, we have heard like a few people
would like to have a deep research API.
I think the more people ask for it, the
more likely it will going to be. Um
maybe something I can like plug and
share is so I um as part of like our
team, we um yesterday we open sourced an
example for how you can build your um
your own deep research using Lancraft
with Gemini. very similar to uh right
very similar to what basically the the
whole deep research agents do. We have a
question we generate queries we then run
like multiple web searches and then like
reflect and see okay was the user
question already asked do I need to do
more research and then you have this
kind of loop for okay do I need to
search other tools uh it's completely
open source it uses all of the things we
have currently seen today Gemini 2.5
flash Gemini 2.0 O. Um, so if you want
your own deep research, that's probably
the best way to start.
Yeah.
So, so there is additional pricing for
the Google search.
We had it like two minutes ago.
Basically, 1,500 uh searches are free.
If you use the native tool, then it
costs money. And all of those tools in a
way enrich your context. So if you use
the URL context tool which goes to a
blog post and the blog post has 10,000
tokens, you pay for those 10,000 tokens
as it's included into your prompt and
then tries to answer your your question.
For like the function calling we had
it's a bit different. Of course we
generate tokens but like the structured
output tokens are less uh and you do the
function calling or like the the Python
call on your side.
Yeah, so that's definitely a good
question. So function calling of course
is much more than one tool and never
going to be calling the weather API
because I mean we have weather apps
right um but it's a good example to show
but what's very cool is so there's
parallel function calling so uh we are
in the Gemini documentation again and
let's assume you want to have a party
and you have function to like power your
disco ball pole ball start the music and
dim the lights right if you like want to
say okay set us into a party mode you
would expect all of them to start at the
same time. And uh with Gemini, we have
parallel two calling. So basically what
Gemini would do instead of generating
one uh object as an output, it generates
a list with basically three objects for
all of the functions you need to call
and then you iterate uh over those and
call them. Parallel tool calling works
if the inputs and outputs of the tools
are not dependent of each other. Right?
I can start my disco ball and the music
at the same time and not okay I first
need to start my disco ball and if it
runs I can like start the music. Um if
you have more of those sequential two
calling um basically you need the input
uh sorry you need the output of the
first function for the input of the
second function basically if you I don't
know you have like some kind of smart
home system um and you want to set the
temperature based on like the outside
weather you would first need to check
what's the weather and then like set
your temperature inside of your house.
Um here would you basically provide
instructions uh using the system prompt
to your model to say okay um to change
the weather you first need to look up
the weather and then set a temperature
and what Gemini would do basically you
have your user prompt it generates the
function the fun structured function you
call the function and instead of
generating a user friendly response it
generates another function call and then
you can call it so basically it
continues this function calling loop
before generating a very nice user
friendly output.
Yes, kind of. I mean, I can like So,
there's I put up an example uh for like
the sequential
um function calling. Uh
there
is
multip function calls and some
sequential and some
workflow something.
Yeah. So currently there's not a good
way to handle like functions who could
time out or like the best way. So it's a
a bit like I would say parallel calling
is like you need to wait for all of the
results to put in into the next one. If
one takes longer, you can basically
provide an error message or not ready
yet or something. But you would need to
to explore how it works on the live API
which is basically our way to create
real-time agents. They are working
something called asynchronous function
calling where um the conversation
continues. So when you think about a
customer support agent which you can
which you talk to, right? It would be
very weird if the agent stops for like
three minutes and doesn't say something
because it needs to look up your
information. So that that's what they
call asynchronous function calling. So
you can continue the conversation with
the agent but the agent runs a two call
and then like injects the response uh
later but that's only for the live API.
Yep.
So um
documentation live API
um it was launched on I think in IO or
cloud next. Um, so yeah, there there you
have like a tool use with life API and
there's asynchronous function calling
um with code snippets for for Python and
JavaScript.
Cool.
Yeah.
No, it's it's more like I start a
function call now. I need to continue my
conversation. I get back the response
later. So instead of like getting the
response, what you get back,
yes, what you get back from the model
could be for example interrupted or
scheduled so that you as a developer
know okay I started something the model
knows it started something and then you
can inject once the your function is the
output is ready put it back into the
conversation and then the model uses
that information to continue.
Y
um so in AI studio we don't have a
feature like this. Um but you can like
use third party tools like lang or arise
AI Phoenix uh but Vortex AI supports
those features.
Okay.
Yeah, that was question. Yeah.
Yeah,
I don't know. The only thing I know is
that so previously there was only Gemini
2.0 flesh available in the live API. But
now we have Gemini 2.5 flash. So
basically the model we used in like the
Jupyter notebooks. Um I guess you have
to try or maybe like reach out to the
people who are working more with it.
Okay, more questions.
Yep.
So, URL context r tool basically works
based on the link you provide. So, if
you provide your own personal blog, it
goes to that link and tries to extract
the information and uses it in the
context. and search basically uses
Google search creates one or multiple
search queries based on the prompt
searches and then provides the outputs
into your prompt. So if you already know
where the source is for your prompt to
create a best answer you all context
could be a good use case for it.
I don't know.
You pay wall content. You mean like
pages?
I don't know. I would not expect to have
it ex like but the live API supports
function calling. So if you have a
subscription or like a way to access
this paid content, you can create your
own function which the model can then
invoke and use as a context for for its
um information.
Okay, cool. Then last section I guess
every one of you might have heard about
model context protocol by now and that's
like either our solution to how we all
align on how to call agents or like
what's the right thing to do. I'm a big
fan of it. Um I think it makes it way
more accessible for people to build
agents especially if we get more of
first party remote MCP servers um where
you can basically focus on building your
agent instead of creating all of those
functions. I mean I'm pretty sure there
are like now a million get weather
functions which can be used and I hope
with um MCP we can like fix this. Uh
what we um shipped and announced at
Google IO is um native integration of
MCP servers inside the Google geni SDK.
So the SDK which we have used during the
whole workshop um allows us to directly
use MCP servers and sessions which makes
it even easier for all of us to
integrate it. So when we um look back at
our function calling example, we needed
to call the function, create a
declaration and all of those different
things. And now with the MCP uh
integration, we can basically uh only
start or initialize our client here. I
created an MCP weather service which
kind of has the same functionality. And
um all of the things we now need to do
is like we use our generate content
method and in our tools argument we
provide our session. So we start our
server,
we create our session
and we provide the session to um the
Gemini SDK and then what happens behind
the scenes is basically the same
function call loop we did manually. It's
like okay what are the tools available?
get all of the tools from the MCP
servers, put them into the LLM call. If
the LLM call makes a function call,
extract the function call, call the MCP
server, get the response from the MC MCP
server, put it back into our
conversation, have the model generate
final response. Um, I guess it's um
probably time to find out if Collab has
node installed and to see if it works.
Okay.
Okay. It doesn't.
What I can do is I can quickly set it up
locally and show you in one second
on how it works.
Okay.
Okay. So, we are back. I'm in cursor.
Same notebook,
same setup. And now I can like use it.
And now basically what happens if I
let's not ask about London, right? We
are in San Francisco. Um let's ask it
about the weather in San Francisco. It
now does all of like the different
function calls and loops behind the
scenes. The MCP server is very simple.
It uses the open Meteor API which is
kind of free to use on a small scale for
testing. Um, so we generate the
output, run all of the MCP calls, might
take a bit longer for the API call, and
then we get back, okay, the weather in
San Francisco today will be 70° Celsius
at zero, and then all of the other
numbers. And that's basically now all
you need to to combine or connect an MCP
server with the the Gemini SDK which is
like I mean it fits on a single screen
like which is easy enough for you to get
started. Um we use here like a a local
running MCP server but it works the same
way with a remote MCP server that's um
also the exercise uh for for this um
part of the workshop. So basically deep
Viki from uh the cognition AI guys
hinder Devon they had a have a very nice
remote MCP server which um can talk to
GitHub repositories. So instead of like
creating a sitio client you can use the
streamable HTTP client and connect a
remote MCP server to Gemini to talk to
it and um yeah basically benefit for one
of the advancements currently happening
in AI.
Do we have more questions?
Y
yeah.
So ADK is um for those of you who don't
know is like agent development kit. It's
an uh agent library which adds a lot of
more abstraction on top of like the the
client uh SDK we used. It makes it a lot
easier to do all of the tool calling. um
integrates MCP server as well makes it
much more easier to manage like multiple
agents or deploy it to cloud. So it has
a lot of like I would say batteries
included. Uh question again depends on
you if you would like to use uh
frameworks or rather prefer building it
yourself. I see a bit benefit of like
getting started very quickly using
agentic frameworks, but the more
abstraction you add, right? The more the
less you know on the first time and then
maybe you need you need to dig a bit
deeper later and all of the the
advancements or speed you get in the
beginning will be your slowdowns in the
future. But ADK is definitely a great
way to start. They also have like tons
of examples. It has support for Gemini
and the Gemini API. So definitely a good
way to to take a look. Yep.
Um, no
I don't think so. Uh, but what you can
do with YouTube links or YouTube videos
is we can ask it to return timestamps
for you as the response and it works
very nicely. So it is very accurately
because so basically a video is more or
less just many images behind each other
right and currently uh when we process
videos it will be done at one frames per
second and you will always have like the
time stamp the image the time stamp the
image that's how Gemini exactly knows at
what place in the video is I don't know
a man jumping or dancing or something.
It's analyzing one frame per second.
Yes.
It depends on your I mean we can I mean
it's part of the section. Um
I use that all the time.
Cool. Cool.
Yeah. But yeah, basically what happens
with videos is I mean videos are 24
frames per second or even more that like
easily lets the the context explode. So
currently what is done is that is we
have one frame per second. So if you
have 60 seconds, it would be 60 images.
Uh which makes it also easy to count how
many tokens it would be. And that's also
how we can fit in um a 1 hour long video
into 1 million tokens. Basically
using the transcript of YouTube or
No, it's
it's all multi-modal natively.
No, I mean you can like easily upload
normal.mpp4 MP4 files and you can ask it
like what was say or said in in the
video.
Okay, cool.
Yeah.
So I'm also like maybe for you if you
don't know is like memory is basically
next to tools what makes an agent an
agent and for memory we have short-term
memory and long-term memory. Short-term
memory is basically your conversation
which is part of your current like state
when you talk to an agent. And long-term
memory is basically
memory or like information about a
previous interaction or something about
the user. And long-term memory is not
like part of the LLM which we need to
provide externally. And me zero is like
something I looked at it because it's
very nice. It's does it implicitly. So
basically it takes the conversation and
tries to create a nice abstraction for
you we which you can include. Um I'm not
sure like what the current state is like
how or what works well with Gemini. I'm
like what I always see or where Gemini
really shines is the long context. So
the better your information extraction
is and like what you provide to the
model based on the memory I think it
works very well. Not sure about those
tool calling memory kind of systems.
Yep.
Yeah.
Yeah. So we are working on 2 million.
Um, not sure when it is like generally
available, but
yeah, like there that was research, but
you know, like the bigger you go, the
more expensive you get. And do you want
to pay like $50 per 1 million tokens?
Yeah.
More questions or everyone working?
Yep. Then
before
functions. Yeah.
Yeah.
No. So the the difference with MCPS now
and what we had previously is that we
don't need to write and define the
functions and the function declarations.
The LLM sees at the end the same exact
exact exact same thing. So if I create
my function declarations manually with a
JSON schema or if I retrieve them from
an MCP server, those are the same things
for the LLM. It's just makes it much
easier to not need to rewrite the same
functionalities over and over again.
Right? If you work at a company and you
want to integrate APIs which you have
internally, there's a pretty big chance
that two teams write the same function
declaration and the same rapper to call
it. And the idea here is to only have
one team needing to write it and
everyone to benefit from it. The same is
with like public APIs like Google Maps,
G Drive. So MCPS gives us a way to
collaboratively create like the best or
like the standard as a way to how to
call it and then everyone kind of can
can implement the MCP tools uh which you
need for your use case.
It's so an MCP server for example
exposes four tools. um you provide all
of those four input schemas which are
like function declarations with a name,
a description and the parameters to your
LLM call and then based on the prompt
and those declarations the LLM in this
case Gemini decides if it should call a
tool which tool could to call or should
it call multiple tools and that's the
same logic we had for normal or have for
normal function calling. So there's no
no difference in that way. The only
difference we see is that
MCP servers being easily available or
imple implementing many tools, people
start to be very easy on how many to
add, right? So we see people at like 50
100 tools. So we need to improve our
LLMs to be able to have them really
know, okay, which is the right tool to
use when you have like 50 different
tools available at once.
So there are examples for ADK to work
with A2A. So A2A stands for agent to
agent protocol which is done by the
Google cloud team. The idea here is uh
to allow companies to build agents in
different frameworks like lench chain,
langcraft, llama index and then have a
an easy way to create multi- aent
systems that one agent can call the
other agent without needing to implement
comp complex logic. Um but the Gemini
SDK is like not directly
but there are great examples for it.
Cool.
Yeah.
So we are working on basically browser
use or computer use use cases which is
available in preview uh which we are
currently testing with a few companies
um would that would allow Gemini to
control UI so it could basically go to
whatever website you want it to go to
and then there's sorry the URL context
tool where you can provide a website and
we would programmatically try to extract
information from it. Of course, it's
like a if it's a super heavy JavaScript
website, there's not much to extract.
That's where like the the browser use
agent would then u be useful
for
Yeah, kind of. Yeah, hopefully coming
soon.
So it will return structured outputs
again based on what you provide. So you
can control a local environment but we
are also working with the cloudr run
team to make it super easy to you for
you to run so that you can like run a
chrome instance on cloudr run uh which
gemini can talk to and control or you
can like control a local
instance
yeah yeah
do authentication
that's a good question I think the whole
industry is currently trying to answer
like what's best way to handle agent
authentication. So the MCP um as a
protocol itself supports OO off. So
basically when you want to connect to an
MCP server which is protected you would
get back a 403 with like not authorized
which can then trigger an off flow on
your client. Maybe you have seen it in
like claw desktop where you get a popup
like to log in with I don't know like
your like atina account or something. So
that's like one way of doing it, but it
definitely needs more work, right? Do
you want your agent to access all of
your emails or all of your GitHub repos
repositories or how can you like scope
it down to like only the one specific
repository, but they are currently like
actively working on it. I know that of
zero will be here tomorrow as well.
Those guys are very great to talk to. I
think I know that they're doing a lot
there. So,
yeah.
Do you mean um citation in when you just
send a regular prompt or citation when
you like use Google search and that have
citations?
Yep.
So that's available in like the Google
search tool. Um and it has information
about which websites was used to to
retrieve. You can um click on the link
directly to see where you land. And then
there's this um
metadata or like chunking or like
crowning support which basically has a
start index and an end index from the
answer and then also which sources were
used. So you technically can highlight
or put numbers behind it to help users
understand okay that part of the
response is generated based on those two
um links.
You mean in in general there are
sometimes citation meta data or
which citation data do you mean
okay
I know or I only know that's part of
like legal and like training that if
there's something referred directly you
need to like provide it. That's why it
is there. That's why it is not always
there. Um it can be there but it doesn't
must be and it's not like for a user to
hey that's coming from there but it's
more like um compliance basically why we
need to have it.
I only know about like the web search
feature.
Ah okay.
So you provide as a context like a
document.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, that's like a very good question.
Currently, we don't have like the same
experience as Entropic has. Um I guess
the base is like to really try and like
different prompting strategies and like
what you want to achieve. Um
yeah. No, but it's like good good
feedback.
Sadly, not yet. I hope hopefully one day
that you can like just here's Gmail,
here's Drive and let's chat. Um, but
currently there's no public remote MCP
server.
I don't know exactly what what are the
reasons. I think the more people ask for
it, the easier it will be that we get
once. So, if you like that's great
feedback. more people um if the more
people are going to use MCP servers the
higher the chances are going to be and I
think in general for MCP to succeed we
need more first party remote servers
right because we cannot build a secure
GitHub MCP servers that's something
GitHub needs to do because they know how
their off system works how you can scope
it um so we really need those first
party MCP servers in the long time
for for AI mode.
I have no idea. I think like so AI mode
you mean about like inside Google
search?
I think in general overall same goes for
like normal Google search is like have
high quality content um try to stick to
like um web standards. Um, I guess same
works here as well,
but I don't know. Sorry.
Yeah.
it should. So if you uploaded a PDF, you
need to make sure that you put a PDF at
the first part of your prompt. So you
like the the automatic um caching works
from the beginning to the end, right? If
you change the beginning, you can never
cache like the long document. But if you
put the the PDF in the beginning and
change the prompt behind it, it should
work. Yes.
Yeah.
Sometimes there's a case where index
provides the starter index out of range
for the length of the
really
curious if you any similar experiences.
No, but if you like have an example for
us to reproduce and to share that would
be very helpful. The only thing I know
is that so sometimes there can be a
start index which can be null which
basically means it's zero like it starts
at the beginning.
Yeah.
No, like if you have an example, please
like send it to me on Twitter or
somewhere like
Okay, that that would be very helpful
because that should not be the case.
Yeah.
Is there any way to actually get
that was
citation from the website that it refers
to.
So that
you only get the website. You just get
the
Yeah. No, like so currently you get like
the the start and end of the response
which refers to something but not the
web part. But that's like like please
put it all together and like send it to
us like very happy to like talk to the
Google search team who is like building
the native tool. Um, yes, super helpful
with like to better understand like what
you need.
Okay,
cool then. Thanks all for coming. Um,
please continue with the workshop. Try
it out. If you have like any questions,
we are very happy to receive any
positive, negative feedback, any ideas,
any pain points you have. Um, we are
available on like social channels. You
can like find me Philip Schmeid
basically everywhere. If not, we open
the GitHub issue or be very noisy about
when when something doesn't work. Uh we
we always try to make sure it we fix it.
Cool. Thanks,
[Music]